the convenience of flight no destination
too far price no object the cost well a
different story especially for the
environment aviation emissions amount to
around five percent of total global co2
emissions which the EU wants to curb
bringing inter continental airlines
flying into and out of Europe into the
emissions trading system but any peace
efforts to include them collapsed after
intense lobbying tough talks with member
states and polarized views in the house
this deal is weak weak weak supporting
this is absolutely shameful from the
beginning the inclusion of the of
aviation into the European system was a
stupid idea it was nothing more than a
tax on industry that supports over 5
million jobs across Europe Europe's
aviation emissions reduction program is
the only one around under the compromise
reached the exemption for
intercontinental carriers will be
extended to 2016 now it's four years of
nothing the pressure is off and we know
Europe has lost what promised to be
tight after a dead heat in committee was
in the end comfortable the mep who
steered the process says he's optimistic
but firm no more exemption stop the
clock as it's known after 2016 what do
representatives of competing
organizations that were doing a lot of
the pre vote lobbying make of it all
first the industry probably the
emissions trading scheme is not that
popular we need to have international
backing of the measures whatever it is
and that's why it's difficult because
this is typically a unilateral
imposition from a particular country or
a group of countries visibly the rest of
the world that we never work next group
campaigning for greener transport
systems it's good to put it in a little
bit of context all of us in the end this
puts few cents to three cents on a liter
of kerosene so you know compare it in
comparison with the enormous tax breaks
the sector is enjoying they don't pay
any tax on fuel they don't pay any vit
on airline tickets it's really a very
very modest
you know attempt to rectify that balance
a little bit if not now perhaps in the
future aviation emissions will be back
in spotlight in 2015 when the next big
UN conference on climate change takes
place in Paris